you are one of the most successful cyber
security law enforcement agents of all
time you tracked and brought down Russ
Albrecht AKA dread pirate robbers who
ran Silk Road and uh Sabu of LOL SEC and
Anonymous who was one of the most
influential hackers in the world so
first can you tell me the story of
jacking down Ross Albrecht and Silk Road
let's start from the very beginning and
maybe let's start by explaining what is
the Silk Road it was really the first uh
dark Market website
um you literally could buy anything
there well
to go back you could there's two things
you couldn't buy there you couldn't buy
guns because that was a different
website uh and you couldn't buy fake
degrees so no one could become a doctor
but you could buy literally whatever
else you wanted you could post things
drugs you could buy a heroin right from
Afghanistan the good stuff uh hacking
tools you could hack for hire you could
buy murders For Hire if you wanted
someone killed now so
when I was an FBI agent I had to kind of
sell some of these cases and this was a
big drug case you know that's the way
people saw Silk Road so internally to
the FBI how I had to sell it I had to
find the worst thing on there that I
could possibly find and I think one time
I saw a posting for uh baby parts
so let's say that you you know had a
young child and that needed a liver you
could literally go on there and ask for
a six month old liver uh if you wanted
to for like surgical operations versus
something darker yeah I never saw
anything that dark as far as people that
wanted to eat body parts yeah um I did
interview a cannibal once when I was in
the FBI that's another crazy story but
uh but that one actually weirded me out
so I just watched uh Jeffrey Dahmer uh
documentary on Netflix and it just
changed the way I see human beings
because it's a it's a portrayal of a
normal looking person
doing uh really dark things and doing so
not out of a place of insanity seemingly
but just because he has almost like a
fetish for that kind of thing he's
disturbing the people like that are out
there
so people like that would then be using
Silk Road not like that necessarily but
people of different walks of life will
be using silk road to primarily what was
the Prime primary thing drugs it was
primarily drugs and that's where it
started it started off with Ross
Albrecht growing mushrooms out in the
wilderness of California and selling
them but really his was more of a
Libertarian Viewpoint I mean it was like
you choose what you want to do for
yourself and do it and in the way Silk
Road kind of had the anonymity is it
used what's called Tor or the onion
router which is an anonymizing uh
function on uh on the Deep Web it was
actually invented by the U.S Navy back
in the mid 90s or so but it also used
cryptocurrency so it was the first time
like we saw this birth on the internet
mixing cryptocurrency uh and uh an IP
blocking software so you know in cyber
crime you go after one the IP address
and trace it through the network or two
you go after the cash and this one kind
of blocked both cash me meaning the flow
of money physical or digital and then IP
is the some kind of identifying thing of
the computer it's your telephone number
for on your computer so yeah all
computers have you know a unique uh for
octet uh numbers you know it's a one two
three dot one two three dot one two
three dot one two three and you know the
computer uses DNS or domain name
services to to render that name so if
you're looking for you know CNN.com your
computer then translates that to that IP
address or that telephone number where
it can find that information didn't sell
code used to have guns in the beginning
or it or was that considered to have
guns or was did it naturally emerge and
then Ross realized like this is not good
it went back and forth uh I think there
were guns on there and he tried to
police it
um you know he uh he told himself the
captain of the boat so he had to follow
his rules so you know I think you took
off those posts eventually and moved
guns elsewhere what was the system of
censorship that he used like selecting
what is okay and not okay I mean it's
alone he's the captain of the boat do
you know by chance if there was a a lot
of debates and criticisms internally
amongst the criminals of what is and
isn't allowed I mean it's interesting to
see a totally different moral code
emerge that's outside the legal code of
society we did get the the server and
was able to read all of the chat logs
that what that happened I mean all the
records were there I don't remember big
debates I mean there was a clear
leadership yeah and that was the final
decision that was the the CEO of Silk
Road and so primarily it was drugs and
primarily out of an ideology of
Freedom which is uh if you want to use
drugs you should be able to use drugs
you should put in your body what you
want to put in your body and when you
are presenting a case of why this should
be investigated you're trying to find as
you mentioned the worst possible things
on there is that what you were saying so
we had arrested a guy named Jeremy
Hammond and he hit himself he was a
hacker and he this would be arrested him
it's the second time he had been
arrested for for hacking uh he used Tor
um and so that kind of brought us to a
point
um the FBI has a computer system where
you look up things uh you know you look
up anything I can look up your name or
whatever if you're associated with my
case
and we were finding at the time a lot of
things in you look it up the case would
end be like oh this is tor it just
stopped like we didn't get any further
yeah so you know we had just had this
big arrest of uh Sabu and took down
Anonymous and and sometimes in the FBI
um the way it used the old school FBI
when you had a big case and you're
working seven days a week and 14 hours
15 hours a day
you sort of take a break the boss kind
of said yeah I've seen a few months go
go get to know your family a little bit
you know and come back but
the group of guys I was with was like
let's find the next big Challenge and
that's when we were finding you know
case closed it was tour case closed it
was tour so said let's take a look at
touring let's see what we can do maybe
we'll take a different approach and Silk
Road was being looked at by other law
enforcement
um but it was taking like a drug
approach where I'm going to find a drug
buyer who got you know the drug sent to
them in the mail and let's arrest up
let's go up the chain but the buyers
didn't know their dealers they never met
them and so you're taking a cyber
security approach yeah we said let's try
to look at this from a cyber approach
and see if we can uh gleam anything out
of it